dès qu'elle a un peu ça dit enfin
justement à quoi
on va juste décalé ça
parlait de ça manque quand même un peu
d'aidé le soudeur ce qu'ils savent ce
qu'est ce que ça manque un peu de
chances qu'avant
et croiser le regard d'un jeune homme
d'environ 17 ans qui a déboulé dans le
fast food de manière assez décidé je me
suis dit qu'est-ce qui me veut et qui
m'a dit je vais te donner de la force
pour ta valise et il a expliqué après à
son pote avec qui il était en décrivant
des chaussures le jet de la main sur son
ventre et tout ce qu'ils étaient lors de
mes trios et j'ai fondu en larmes en dix
ans mais en fait moi c'est bon là je
peux aller élever des chèvres à guingamp
ça y est c'est long c'est à dire qu'en
fait un môme de 17 ans qu'a pris
conscience que ce qu'était que
l'endométriose qu en parle à son pote
qui se rend compte que c'est grave et
qui me prend dans ses bras pour donner
de la force en fait c'est pas moi qui
prend dans ses bras c'est nous tout
jeu si j'aurai en voilà j'ai enfin
quelques fait quelque chose vaut bien
mais vraiment
[Musique]
à l'arrivée le bâti à giacchino dit
à 9 heures
un ami
et commenté dans un endroit autre corps
on
aller voter
c'est ben oui ça va bon assez grand
constat away tu crois que j'ai quand
même place là-dedans au en rouge jambes
à la louche pas la louche
[Musique]
ca
79 me
les gars gardez je crois je viens de
découvrir un truc chez moi si je ramasse
le livre
je me remets
wesh
a donné ça continue
c'est pour ça